And we are live. Good morning, America.
>> Um yes, welcome back. Welcome back.
Welcome back.
Okay, I'm just going to check if we are
live everywhere, but I think so.
YouTube is good. Yeah. What? YouTube is
good. Yep, yep, yep.
Nice and
All is good. Bam, bam, bam. Talking
point. Introduction? Introduction? Yes.
Okay.
Uh something is bumping into your mic, I
think. Like uh
Let's see if I have the correct one.
Uh is that like your cable against the
mic? Yeah, but it should not work. I
have the other one.
Okay.
This one is better, right? I think so.
Yes, should be good now.
Nice. Nice.
Ooh.
Nice. Yeah, yeah, that's
let's go. That's better. Yes, and thanks
for the comments.
We saw you in the comment section.
Okay. So,
I was still building a company with Open
Claw. This is so last week. Again, it
change all the time. No, we have a new
app. It's called Paperclip and it's uh
going to help you build your zero human
company because it just it just better,
right? So, like until the next one, but
yeah, whatever. Uh
so, in this live we are going to um
build uh
the Open Sora
because Open AI killed Sora, but I still
want to create some funny AI video. So,
we need an open-source solution. That's
what we are going to build with
Paperclip. And uh yeah, let's go. Let's
go.
>> [laughter]
>> That was a good one.
So,
is it the old Excel paperclip?
Uh almost. From like 15 years ago? The
one was really smart and helped you all
the time.
So, it's like um I'm I'm pretty sure
it's like a Portia
uh like you know the uh the app that I
showed you. So, it's coming from uh
video game called Paperclip where you
it's a point and click and you have to
click to create paperclips.
So, and then it's always upgrading like
your like the webpage. So, you So, then
you auto click and then you can develop
an AI Mhm. uh to
um
create more paperclips.
And at the end of the game, the AI is so
advanced that it terraform the uh planet
Earth to create more paperclips. So,
there is no more human life and etc.,
etc. Only paperclips. Exactly, just to
make paperclips because the AI becomes
sentient, but still has one mission
paperclips. Yeah. And it terraform Earth
and then it goes to the universe to
steal
And that's coming from that. Yeah.
Okay. That's Paperclip. And that evolved
into the perfect tool to build your
company. Yeah, again, like like said in
the intro until next week, but I I
really like this one. It's pretty
straightforward. The onboarding is
great. Really nice
uh experience. I'm I'm not sure. You
didn't test it before, right? I didn't
test it, so I'm curious. Yes, nice.
You're going to show it, right? Yeah,
that's what we're going to do. But uh
okay, before that, let's Are you going
to dash run up front to build Sora or
just
>> [laughter]
>> going to show us how?
No, I don't I don't do that anymore.
So, that's the terminal, but that's for
later. I'm going to replace that
window. Bam.
Back. Look at that beautiful website.
Uh so,
back, back, back. Paperclip open-source
orchestration from zero human zero human
companies. Hire AI employees, set set
goals,
automate jobs and your business run it
runs itself.
That sounds perfect. Yes, it's um
everything turns around one mission.
When you set up that in the onboarding,
I'll show you after, but you set up one
main mission and then you create a task
which is basic it's not even like a PR
PRD or just a GitHub issues, whatever.
It's just a task for the AI to to do.
So, then the task can be whatever the
whatever it can be, but
it it yeah, it it works in as a business
unit more than a task or job to do. I
mean, yeah, like a business unit more.
This task. Is that clear?
Somewhat, but you will show us and that
will make it clear.
And okay, so to start it, it's just one
liner and then it's like thanks to AI
it's just does everything except like
I guess because we have developer
computer it just straightforward.
Maybe for it was straightforward, too.
Some
yeah, to wait for whatever, whatever.
Looks like that.
That's the dashboard and see like so,
you kind of like the same UX/UI than
linear.
Which is like like a project management
app.
Uh it's straightforward and that looks
like
Open Claw, you know, like Alex Fein
diagram about like oh yeah, I hired like
20 employees and
yeah, they are mine now.
But it sets up for you. You don't have
to set up everyone up separately. No,
you do.
Oh. You you build the company you want,
right? Like for example, like
CTO, [clears throat] CMO, another CTO,
whatever. That's going to be for SaaS
for example, but if you want to create a
company around marketing or something
like that, you will have a different
setup.
Okay.
Uh manage business goals, not pull
request. Yes, yeah. Exactly that like
it's business goal. That's a complete
shift of uh
um mindset I found I found it
interesting. Everything you need to run
on this company. Bring your own agents.
So, we're going to use uh Claude and
uh Codex. Mhm. Alignment, uh bits, okay.
Cost control, so you can you're going to
see the
uh usage by token. Yeah, set limits and
everything. Exactly.
Uh
bring your own boat. Yeah, you can also
set up like connect all the
agent management like even Open Claw.
Mhm.
So, you set up Open Claw and you have to
connect your AI agent.
>> Yeah, I don't really understand why you
need Open Claw inside Paperclip, but uh
but in the video that
Mhm. [clears throat]
Dota, so the
founder and the like main contributor of
the project uh explained that Paperclip
is the organization and Open Claw is the
employees. I don't know exactly what it
means, but uh yeah, whatever.
Um okay, and then you can yeah, Claude
Codex, that's the main one we're going
to use. Uh keep your agent aligned on
the goal.
>> [clears throat]
>> Company mission, make 2 million in
revenue with a number one AI note taking
and then you
you go down into yeah, project goal,
agent goal, task.
Mhm. [clears throat] So, that's it. I
think that's it. Yeah, cost management,
whatever.
Uh one deployment, many company. We
don't care about that.
And okay, cool.
Uh on X
uh
Dota founder, he's an NFT guy coming
Yes.
Like most NFT people going into AI.
>> exactly.
Uh we just open-sourced
Paperclip, the orchestration uh
layer for zero human companies is
everything you need to run an autonomous
business or chart, whatever, whatever.
Uh one liner, boom.
Uh Paperclip is right for you if you
have 20 Claude card tabs open and can't
remember who's doing what.
Yeah, thanks. Thanks. Yes. Sounds
familiar. Yes. Use different type of
agents. Yes. Mhm. Want agents working
for you 24/7 with editable work and
cost. I want an autonomous business, not
manage pull request.
I I I think it's really strong, right?
Like uh it it take the technical layers
out of um
um like you don't care about how it
built
basically. It's it's business goal. It's
business oriented. If your business goal
is saying make money, Yeah. it just does
it.
May- maybe.
Maybe. [laughter]
That's how it should work.
>> Yeah.
I think maybe that's the number one
business goal everybody puts in. Make me
money. Like one of the latest video
about paperclips is saying like yeah,
Paperclip is not that great because
people are just like burning token
without any solid output anyway, so it's
Yeah. useless again. But that's the same
thing for every tool you use, yeah? The
writing the prompt into like a 10-pager
makes it work so much better. Exactly.
And also like it's kind of true because
how many billion dollar company we got
since like the agent age and
orchestration 24/7 stuff. Like
yeah, some people make some money but
uh Yeah, maybe the billion dollar people
are just not screaming that they are
making billion dollars. I mean, I would.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, or just keep quiet. We're like
five times more and then say, "I made
some money."
>> Yeah, on the side. On the side.
>> Yeah.
But okay, so that I think that's it.
And
just open source be good with that.
GitHub repo
This almost 7,000 fork and 42 stars in
like a couple of weeks, so That's more
than I ever did, man. Yeah.
Okay,
contributors 55. Whatever. And I think
that's it.
We set up a clip yet 20 20. Okay, so all
of that we have it. Oh, and
also they have company, where is it?
A company repository multi company like
where you can basically import the
organization.
I think it's in another repo.
Yes, companies. Um
So
you can
import exactly
other companies people like the the
setup like the org chart. Mhm. You can
just
switch it and like for example G stack
It's it's really popular right now
because
he's the
current president of YC and he's using
that to via paper clip to just keep
shipping
product [clears throat]
and even if he's busy get those
agents running for them. Okay,
interesting.
Okay, so I think that's it.
Okay,
be like whatever. So the website key
concept all good. We're good. Cool.
Okay, so we have that and I can share
back the terminal.
Back, replace.
So terminal path.
So I want to build
open Sora and I'm going to take the
line liner.
You guys should deinstall everything.
Yes, sir.
So the goal Okay, okay, okay.
So OpenAI shut down Sora. I want an app
to create content.
You want to see if you can get Disney.
Yes, exactly. To partner up with you.
>> Like yeah, Disney closed the deal. I
want to get it back.
And we will show you here how.
>> [laughter]
>> So Paperclip AI onboard, yes. Boom.
Back and it really look like
uh
It really look like a open close setup,
right?
Yeah, well. All of that. So that's it. I
already run it once, so that's why it's
fast. Okay.
Um [clears throat]
Can I onboard Oh, yeah, I'm going to
show
uh back back
replace
base
to
path.
So that's not Okay, I I Okay, so that
should be the first screen when you run
it for the first time. Mhm.
And that's it. Okay, so
I want open Sora.
I want I want to build the
number one number one AI
uh content mobile app
uh which will replace
Sora from OpenAI.
Uh I want
I think that's it.
Yeah.
That's
That's basis. Yeah.
That's the mission. That's the goal.
I want to make
1 million
uh
uh band by
Q2
2023.
Cuz it's important to have a
>> [laughter]
>> That would be so weird if it said,
"Okay."
Let's do a mistake. Yeah, let's do that.
Okay, create your first agent.
We'll see you because
I'm CEO [__] Mhm.
I can choose Claude Code or Codex. I'm
going to put Claude Code and I'm going
to take the big one Opus. I'm just What
do you see when you press the more agent
adapter types? Uh
Under the two options. Uh
Oh, yes.
So Gemini open code cursor by
open Claude gateway.
What? Oh, maybe I don't have it. Maybe
that's why it's not uh
I don't have it on this computer.
Okay, cool. So the CEO will be Opus 4.6.
Uh first task we are going to give the
CEO to do is to hire the first
uh engineer which will be the CTO.
And
uh yes, and that's it. Mhm. Show number
one back.
Summary of everything to do.
Great open. Now we are on
the dashboard. Okay, cool. CEO is
already working. Boom boom boom.
Uh I should see
an inbox alert once it's complete Oh.
Does not exist currently.
Okay, okay. Looks like it's good.
Agent live still going or what?
Yes.
Uh so I I'm I'm I I've clicked on the
on the current task and I can see it
run. Mhm. Running. Back. Good. I'm CEO
company. Okay, still going. Perfect. Uh
I will
add a project onboarding but I won't
uh
desktop
Uh no, I want mobile app. Mobile.
Uh mobile.
Back. Uh
open Sora
mobile
app. Back and I can I will give it the
repository I've created here.
Back.
Path and
I need to find the
path of the repo so it's not
uh lost
Back. So what I set up really just like
to give it some context of like the
GitHub and the
folder where to build everything.
Great project. And your folder is empty
right now.
>> Yeah, I only have GitHub connected.
Yeah, exactly.
I've I've set up not nothing except I
run the
Paperclip once to
to just check if it's working correctly.
And I've set up [__] Atlas
connection because later we're going to
use it as a database. And
desktop
>> [clears throat]
>> and
uh
and get and the the GitHub repo. So now
I have two alerts in the inbox to check.
Oof.
I have to approve the fact that he will
create the agent. He doesn't say how
much he's paying for the CTO. Not
nothing, bro. Nothing.
Um cool. I and what I'm going I want to
do is Evan
Uh no, I will I will speak to the CEO. I
will I will add to the CTO. I will ask
that after.
Back. Unread. Mark as read. Is it done?
Nice. Okay, so CTO funding engineer
timing now. Blah blah blah. After CTO
architecture dedicated model
hiring principle. What?
Hiring plan. Okay.
Still going.
Okay.
I am because I confirmed the fact that
we will create the engineer. So just set
up the setting up the agent right now.
Uh routine we can explore that. So I I I
expect that to be just a cron job that
it will repeat like uh
all the time. I can set up a new goal
for the
company or project.
So for example plan active
active and
task company team agent. Okay, nice.
Uh company team agent. Tell the CEO to
contact Disney CEO and ask him to test
your app.
Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh
uh
CEO
Um okay, so
yet
nah
Disney
rights
>> [laughter]
>> Disney
>> [snorts]
>> characters
We need the license.
It's like a big goal. License license.
Yes. The license
uh
Disney characters
characters and create new
app.
Back. And I'm going to do that to
team. No.
Agent.
I want to put that. Okay.
I can even
task. Okay, I don't know exactly how to
do that, but yeah, whatever. So, okay,
and I will create another goal.
Plain active.
Build
number one.
AI
We need to reach
number one in
the App Store.
>> App
App Store and
Google Store. I don't know exactly what
how it's going to do that, but enjoy.
Yeah, let's go.
Okay, what was the CTO CEO is going?
Honestly, I
I like the interface, but it's pretty
straightforward.
>> It looks really good.
In progress, still in progress. Why is
it still in progress?
Once approved
I will assign what?
How do you approve it? Yeah, it's it's I
think it's supposed to be approved
already. No?
Um
Update hiring plan publish and higher
submitted. Yeah, I've done that, bro.
Yeah, at the at the bottom you have
linked approvals.
Oh. Yes, approved.
Okay, so what I'm going to do is update
and
>> [clears throat]
>> I have
approved approved it already.
Please check it. Did you
hire right? Check.
So, basically like the comment is a
prompt.
Mhm. Because now you have also have a
live run again, right? And yeah, let me
check my account.
I think Okay, so I have the CTO here now
and I'm going to assign new task. And
that's it. That's how you prompt the new
agent. So,
I
new hires
I want to
have
a
front end QA engineer
attach
a
all using
Open Open 4.5.
Cool. Pretty shoes
um
front will manage
the front end of the landing page and
mobile design
and
back end will
create the API
and anything back end related. Is there
a difference between creating an issue
and creating a task?
That's a good question. I think it's I
think it's the same. Okay.
Because when you create an issue
It creates a task to fix the issue. Yes,
I Oh, oh, maybe yes.
Yeah, okay. So, yeah, I give an issue
and then it will like it can have like
multiple tasks inside the issue, I
think.
>> I think so, yeah. Yeah, makes sense.
Back end related QA will
double check everything and write
test.
Back path. Okay.
So, now if I do new hires and I see that
pretty shoes, okay.
Waiting for run output.
Activity for the issue created. Okay,
blah blah blah.
Inbox
hire your first engineer. I think that's
done.
Confirm CTO hires approved and active.
Approval, yes. The new is live.
Define technical architecture. Yes, yes.
Okay.
And now I can see the critical,
nice. Define architecture. We are
building the mobile app store
replacement targeting 1 million back you
to enjoy. If you can do that, that would
be helpful.
Primary model provider pluggable clean
API runway Pika. Okay.
I think I want to use replicate and file
AI, that would be easier.
Ask it if it's easier and let's see what
it says. Yep. MVP plan down. Yes, so see
Okay, so all of that
it make like architectural choices for
us.
Back end or no, nope, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
Program queue for the
for the queue system, that's good. Okay,
so
leave comments. I
Okay, so
I said I want mobile, yes. Yes. Yes.
I want to use
parts
providers like
replicate replicate and
AI instead of
clean
back end
next, yes.
No, nest, yes. Nest, yes.
Tags supervise
DB [__]
Atlas. I have
cluster ready.
All right.
Back
super baby, okay.
Clerk for auth.
Infra railway.
I have pre-read it
on AWS.
Repo to mono repo app mobile web package
API, that's cool.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
In the mono repo
add website
to promote the mobile app.
Okay, MVP text to video image to video
blah blah blah.
Free pro 15 creator 40, okay. Hard cut
advanced analytics social feed web app
custom model training.
Okay, cool.
Let's go.
Nice. And see like I really like that
because you don't pick up models like
you know to prompt and everything.
It just a task, right? So,
I mean
it makes sense, right?
Yeah, it
it just does whatever you ask and it
finds out how.
Like And okay, so also
Oh, can I see that my company
is building is building. See CEO CEO is
higher three
three different engineers. Yes, because
I I I ask it, right? Yeah, that's cool.
It's a it's a task.
It was a task here and see like the
speed and stuff like yes, it's pretty
good. I think it's even
faster than Open Clo.
Blocked
new hire, why is that blocked?
Your board member has approved the
higher request. Okay,
he needs to Oh, cool.
Back, back,
back.
Yeah,
when you create an agent, I need to
validate it, but that's it.
Back. Did it also add codex what you
asked?
Yeah, it did, right?
Yeah, yeah, you wanted to use codex for
the AI on the agent.
Now I I Now because I'm I'm at like a 6%
of my weekly
So, yeah, yeah. I will keep I will keep
Claude.
But yeah, like for example, what I would
do here is the QA engineer would be
codex codex AI or something and then I
will
Yeah, okay, okay, wait. I can probably
do that if I do
that and
plan
review.
If I want to have
plan review
and code
>> [snorts]
>> review in real
time
when the task is done.
Who would we do that?
Is it a job for
or
or do
we need a QA
engineer?
Maybe it will understand that.
Tag to-do path recent issues.
Like
that's proper orchestration, right? Like
crazy.
Okay, we can even think about
GTM
tag.
Should we build
in public
way hire CMO?
If yes.
Do we hire a CMO? Look. Laugh.
Hop la.
And select.
That's it, man. Like it's it works
better than open claw. Yeah, it's also
much easier.
It's crazy. Because setting up an
additional agent open claw just doing
the
the entire setup of the folders and all
the files and Yeah.
If you're making a bigger
bigger pool of many agents, it's giving
issues. And here it looks like it's just
it just does it and works. Exactly. It
just keep going, keep like it's it's
I don't know, man. Like it's it's it's a
nice experience. Mhm. I hire you first.
Okay, so what
>> And they even did some work on the
design.
On the
>> It's nice. Oh, yeah, yeah, no one
person.
Um
Okay, so progressive scaling steps is
active and delivering working on
architecture at all. Oh, it's nice.
Nice. Nice. Nice.
Uh CTO is working on submitted screen
engineer hire request. Yes, approval.
What's second engineer approved or break
one map into sprint task and beginning
delegation.
Damn. Cool.
Okay, define technical architecture and
set up the project repo. We are building
the number one Okay.
Technical architecture revised take back
decision cross platform uh
Expo. Yes, Expo router. Okay, no
problem.
Uh ship back YouTube by consuming best
in class generator
by the eye. Okay.
Replicate broad model catalog.
TypeScript, that's exactly Yeah, so
cool.
Infrastructure folder house free credit.
Cool.
Okay, apps. Okay, okay, okay. Marketing
website.
MVP uh core feature text to video
generation image to video video library
aspect ratio control
YouTube, Instagram, export and share
from a bomb built for everyone.
Uh
advanced video editing. Okay.
Real-time collaboration team workspace
custom style. Okay, Laura fine-tuning.
Damn, that's pretty that's pretty cool.
It's thinking about everything. Yeah,
now that's that's amazing. I don't know
if they are doing something in the
background or it's like the model is
getting like
How do you get to that?
You know what I mean?
Uh
is that system?
>> Yeah, I don't know. And otherwise, if
it's research it's doing it really fast.
Yeah, it's not like
Uh
>> Because if you do this on Codex, you
have to do a deep research and that
takes at least 15 minutes. Like how can
they do that? That fast.
Yeah, because the model is the model.
Like
Oh. Yeah, you don't switch it.
Maybe it because maybe because you
mentioned Sora.
It just looked up on Reddit or whatever
what they are using. Oh, even like
like to generate that kind of text, you
don't need a big model anyway. You like
if you are if you use a a fast one, can
I see which one has been used in for
that task? Yeah, why are you doing it on
the double the double spending to
Oh, [__]
>> be lightning fast. Oh, [__]
>> [laughter]
>> No, don't do that, please. So, uh
go to the dashboard and check your
costs.
Yeah, oh yeah, true. Okay, wait.
Adapter cloud cut. So, here I'm in the
run. Okay. Mhm. Yes, 7 minutes 4 minutes
ago. So, yeah, 2 minutes to create a
plan.
Cost, okay. Output 3K. That that's
that's nothing.
Uh
where is the model? Project blah blah
blah.
Source task.
Project.
Agent.
Okay, uh paperclip here, please. Please
redact that [__] please. Thank you.
Uh I see. Model is Yeah, Sony 4.6.
Okay.
But is that plain mode?
I don't know.
Yeah, we need to I mean s-
3 minutes for a plan, that's kind of
like
normal, right?
But yeah.
Uh plan review if I want to Yes, uh
CTO recommendation plan review in real
time on a pair engineer CTO not QA.
Okay. Ah, yeah. Could use the CTO to
review all of the Mhm.
all of the agent. Okay, real time. Do we
need a QA hire funnel no dedication at
count needed yet engineer on test
coverage and variable once we have
stable feature surface and in
regression. It's cutting costs.
Yeah.
Uh had a lightweight here template and
required policy. I can draft that as
Yeah, and see recommended next step. I
like that.
Yeah. You should be able to just say
keep on going and it just keeps on going
to the next step until it's done.
Good. We hire
uh
we are
in the old then.
Back.
Uh okay.
Uh I want I would like to see the app
now.
Blocked. Yeah, it didn't What? build
yet, right? It's only
>> Yeah, no, I don't think so.
Uh all report to CTO blah blah blah.
It's unblocked. Maybe.
Uh
Is it
still blocked?
Back.
Issues. Back. Back. Back. Plan preview.
Okay.
And so, this one is blocked, but I just
commented.
No.
Uh QA engineer database icon close up
close up close. Okay.
Blocker CTO on board must approve.
I think it's done, right?
Back.
Inbox. Plan review if I want
Uh
records on a pair engineer CTO. Okay, so
that's done. No, do not fire the QA
engineer. I checked the org and already
have a QA engineer on staff. My prior
comment was about
uh
QA at count. What?
Okay.
Uh clarify that Not blocked PR engineer
review and merge QA test after merge.
Okay.
Uh
Good. Uh implement industry
best
practices.
Back. Okay, cool. And now I want to see
the app. So,
I'm going to ask
uh
build the MVP.
Yes. I want to see the MVP of the
website and the mobile app.
And
you do it
yourself.
Yourself with the help
of
your team.
Let's [__] go.
Great issue. Okay, so and while it's
doing Okay, cost. Uh cost it's free.
It's free. Yeah. It's within your sub.
Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh Usage, how many million tokens did
you use? Um road
>> it on the overview.
Usage 3.9 million.
Wait, already?
Yeah, already.
I'm correct, right? Uh not talking
across request event. I guess so.
Uh that's a lot, no? Yeah, well,
if that wasn't
if you did that on Opus, that would be
like $20 already. Yeah, true. Yeah, for
the plan.
CEO subscription 1 million.
Okay.
Uh by project mobile. Okay, that that's
pretty cool.
I mean, you can have that in your
company with like real guys and see how
much they consume. Like you know, um
Yeah, it's like they say at the bigger
companies, right? If you are a senior
dev, you have to consume at least so
many million tokens, otherwise you're
not performing. Yeah, exactly.
100%.
Oh, uh look ah
Uh wow, wow, wow, everyone's working.
Look. Look.
>> [laughter]
>> You're going to be so busy. Yeah, let's
go.
Uh back. Back. Okay, inbox. Bam.
Uh approved GTM. Oh, yes, GTM. Are we
going to contact Disney or not?
Yeah, of course. Uh it's Short answer to
both questions. Yes and yes. Burden
public we can
we cannot outspend a cabinet on
distribution. Earn reach through
transparencies your best bet. Start
immediately before the product ships.
Hire a CMO. Yes, stop.
Stop as eight of growth for this stage.
Someone need to own content, community,
and product management full-time.
Uh
back. Okay, you can just say I approve
and it will put in the request. Just
message. Yes. Uh tag, I will see my
agents proceed.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, and then yes to everything.
>> Yeah.
I mean, like yes.
Uh tag GTM okay, path build MVP. It's
coming and plan review industry best
practice for plan review and code
review. What?
Okay.
Uh engineer plan CTO review within from
30 minutes or schedule uh 50 minutes
think okay.
A code review process or ship okay okay
okay okay.
Okay, yes yes fantastic. But like wait
oh okay, so there you rewrote
everything. The checkout recon new to
foundation to do checkout.
Okay, just do the job. Just do just
finish it. Yeah. Show me the money.
Yeah, exactly.
Uh hire but why are we coming back to
the market down?
Is it still block? Oh, okay. Are
approved active? Okay, we're good.
Okay.
So that If you have like 50 agents
running, it will be insane and how many
messages you get.
>> Yeah. I I mean also like I today I
listen a podcast and they were talking
about something in the valid called
token anxiety. And if you don't if you
do something and you're not burning
token, you're losing your time and
you're missing opportunities, bro. Yeah,
right. So you just spend everything as
much as possible even on stupid [__]
just to keep on going. Exactly.
You you have just a uh have
>> [laughter]
>> add byte on Opus 4.6 so you can burn
tokens. Yeah, so so now in the valley
they talk like hi. I'm Mitchell, how
many tokens are you burning? Exactly.
Yeah, nice to meet you. I'm CEO. I don't
care how many token did you use today.
Yeah, exactly.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh okay hire You need to approve. Yes,
I'm approving the same head of growth.
Let's go.
Uh first task after building public
content strategy and first week of post,
let's go.
path
Uh so the task where is the task? There.
Awesome.
Um proceed. It's
approved.
What's next?
tag
Okay, path content GTM that's down
that's just a oh okay, it's let's go.
Approve proceed. Boom.
Uh hire your first engineers. Are you
are you hiring more or no?
Uh CTO is open MVP build with that team
good things are moving. Nice.
I can be closed. Okay, can I close the
issue? Should I close them?
Oh, okay done. Okay, nice.
Cool. So we're done. We're done we're
done GTM CMO build the MVP.
It's coming up.
Okay.
Uh there is a workspace apps API It's
actually building. Let me check
uh if we have something.
Uh LS
Ooh.
What what does what does stuff? Ooh,
what is your terminal showing?
Um yes. Uh
so that there is files there is files in
it. Okay, I'm opening cursor now.
Um tag
W opens wrong path.
tag and I'm going to replace it.
window
Uh tag
path
Let's go. Apps API mobile
API mobile web okay, nothing in there.
Okay, it's coming it's just the
scaffolding right now. Mhm.
But
uh that was good. Yeah, I asked
>> It's already building the UI, right?
Yeah. Uh yeah. But let's not spoil it. I
want the CTO to tell me what's what's up
when it's going to be ready.
Uh tag path build MVP tag
Um so now we have
a CTO CMO
QA guy back end front end
That looks like a startup and
Um okay, yes also another an interesting
um page is like the skills. Mhm. Uh so
obviously it's like every
other skills out there, right? But what
I want is
G stack.
Uh yes. So I want that.
Uh
No.
I want So if I I can import the
repository G stack
tag
So Gary Tan
Uh Gary Tan exact cloud code setup uh 23
opinionated tools that serve as a CEO
designer engine manager blah blah blah
blah
Um
So I'm going to take that. I'm going to
put it into paper clip. Mhm.
Yeah. I can load it directly the path of
the GitHub
Ooh, that's cool. And boom. It will just
download, install, and do everything
itself.
>> Exactly.
Um
And that's it.
Uh tag I can I can read the skill.
Uh and so the one I want yeah, plan
review blah blah blah. So you can
explain it like
Uh
G stack
Explain it how to use it. Mhm.
Uh I was advising kick off social
tonight from the way I was asking for me
for code X code review plan review
support so I came home and ship it same
night.
Alex is amazing blah blah blah blah
blah. Um okay, so uh
G stack
G
stack and paper clip
path
Uh yes. Okay, so that's the
one of the article that I explained how
to use G stack and paper clip at the
same time.
Uh clear so it's fine. I want that.
Oh.
Is that the inception of
Yes. Your engineer team install G stack
engineer team 2 minutes. Office hour
takes your rough ID and turn it into a
real plan by asking smart question and
proposing three approaches which is like
back and forth you talk with the AI to
find like a different version of the ID.
Challenge your scope like a CEO would
find the 10 star product hiding inside
your feature list Mhm. and plan
engineering lock down the architecture
with diagram edge cases and failure
modes.
blah blah blah blah blah. So all of that
you have you can just go through all of
those skills and now paper clip will
have those too, right? So hopefully it
will ship better
software. Yes. And by the way, I should
also load the front end skill.
Um front Yes.
Uh front end and true
big
skills
Uh
Where is it?
front end
Yeah.
GitHub
X
path
Is that Anthropic? Yeah, Anthropic scale
bam.
path So if I do that and I do all that
path
Yeah, um
Uh it's getting imported.
Oh.
Yeah, from design. Uh it's
aesthetic guideline boom
cool
I should hire a designer.
I want to hire a designer. Designer
Uh should we hire a designer agent
working with the front end engineer
to focus
on
the UX UI
Um
use
Anthropic
front end skill
to make the best app
in the world.
tag
Uh
Thanks for coming up here Scaris. How
long have you guys been blah blah blah.
How long have you guys been using paper
clip for?
Uh I
this week. I just tried this week and
on base on like I connected to my
personal SAS.
Uh it works great.
And now we are just like
we are exploring it as we go during the
live stream.
Yes, becoming a professional when using.
Exactly. Uh
This has so much nicer UI for agent
creation than open
>> [clears throat]
>> 100% like I and I like the
I really like the
the UX UI the onboarding clear as [__]
Like, it's
awesome. Yeah, it's so easy to do.
>> Yeah.
No, no, right. 100%. Like, yeah, like
Mitchell, like you should 100% like give
it a try. Um
once you fix all of the actual issues,
security stuff. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Um yeah, use it.
Like, so I think it's coming because I
saw some
pull request about it. Mhm. Um but I
would like to have a chat. It's kind of
weird
to have paperclip.
Uh
so it's here in the upcoming features.
Uh artifact that see your chat.
I I think it would make sense to have a
CEO chat in the app because
um
first, I would like to generate like
like
I don't I don't I don't care of like the
you could even like simplify that UI
with the new issue [clears throat] and
just saying like yeah, I want to hire an
engineer would be just like not a issue
title. It would be
uh just chats.
And I I I'm thinking about hiring a
designer
uh to make it a better, right?
Uh yeah, what's up? Uh GM GM.
Uh you defend them from London. Yeah,
same time line, right? So
what's up? Looking really good. Yes,
yes. Uh Mitchell, yes. Okay.
Um and
yeah, I I could see myself like
launching some
side project at least with that for
sure, 100%. Oh, yeah. I would for sure
just start using it on some small
projects and then just keep on scaling.
Yeah.
Because um
like with so with Genfi on my code base
um
I mean, you can I I had like a hard time
to
having it
um
just checked everything and then on my
own code base, I would have been faster
via the CLI anyway. Mhm. Right? Because
I already have the whole setup.
Yeah, and it's so big, it's hard for all
these AIs to read whatever you have. Uh
under the hood, it's still like Codex
and Claude code Codex and yeah, Codex
and Claude code. So
>> [clears throat]
>> I don't know exactly how it would work
from a project that already exists
and get paperclip on top of that.
Yeah, maybe it can build on some
documentation depending on the readme
files and whatever you have. True. Yeah,
I need to explore a little bit more, but
yeah, like to take it like uh
to put your hands on it, I think it's
easier to do it like from scratch for
sure. It would be cool to just have it
create a duplicate
uh system with the same requirements,
but And let's just let it run and then
compare how it is building everything
with yours
to optimize it. I was thinking about
just scratching Genfi and then uh learn
have like a Yeah, and then hope it's not
better than what you have built.
But like
uh bro, like
I went from let's So, the last 2 weeks,
I went uh I
implemented like the conventional UI
Mhm. and then agent.
And since I tried paperclip, I just
switched that. I put it on the on the on
the side and now I have the same
architecture than paperclips, but only
for content.
Oh, that's cool. Like, I moved I moved
this dashboard like yeah, I took like
this dashboard inbox and issues
setup
as a
You create your own content team. The
video person, an image creation.
So
>> While you while keeping like all of the
studio and all of the other tools that
I've already built like the workflow and
stuff, Mhm. but the first interface you
arrived on Genfi now will be
uh a paperclip like interface.
I haven't I haven't kept like the the
brand stuff like the brand switcher like
yeah.
How is it going with the code?
I just I tell Claude No, no, no. With
this one here on paperclip.
>> yes, yes. How was paperclip proceeding?
Uh okay, so where is the build?
TMO is down, designer GTM. Where is my
Oh, build MVP. Nice.
Tech edge.
Trying all of those tools is like having
a second job. Yes.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Uh but I mean, you can try it and if you
spend more than couple of hours on it,
it's probably a good one.
Yeah, if it is working after an hour,
then it's a good one. If you're still
setting up and and doing debugging,
Yeah. Yeah, that's bad. Uh still 18
errors. Let's check what the actual
error was. Okay, so keep going, bro.
Keep going.
Open run.
Um
back. Build the MVP. Okay, paperclip
skill. You're running a bit. Okay,
whatever.
Run skill.
Right.
Okay, okay.
The root OS has my code which import
create user, find email, whatever,
whatever. Back end engineer might
replace my in-memory user model with
Mongoose, but didn't update the root.
Okay, enjoy, boys.
Enjoy.
Uh back.
Oh, 18 minutes ago. What the [__] Oh,
okay. It is still working.
But wait, it's it's midnight already.
Damn. Yeah.
I guess we're not going to make money in
less than 1 hour. Not within an hour,
but you said Q2. Maybe you should have
said within an hour.
True. Q2 is a long time. Um Did you do
it? Did you Did you check it?
The the what?
The leaked Claude source files. No, I I
was working on this [__] but I Okay,
with the source code leaked, did you
turn on all of the IDN features? Did you
turn on all of the IDN features? No.
Did you? Did you try? No, I didn't look
into it. I I was still waiting. People
are still coming up with new things.
I did see that they are flagging you if
you
swear at the at the AI.
>> [laughter]
>> Really?
Yeah, yeah, really. I'm [__] Oh,
yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> I You you cannot see what they're doing
with it, but
and people are coming with so many
things. I think one person also posted
online that he found two bugs why this
uh
use
any of using so much usage.
What do you mean? Like uh Like, people
were complaining that they were like at
10% for just saying hi and he just said,
"Okay, I found two bugs and it is this
issue, this issue and they should fix it
and then we can go back to normal."
Is
So, maybe by leaking it, they had like
instantly 500 people working and
optimizing the wrong code.
But
but but like they should have Claude 5
and it should be better than [__]
everyone else on earth. Yeah. How cool
would it be if people now use Codex to
optimize Claude? Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh it's it's on um
Codex has Claude as a contributor.
Yeah, that's cool.
But I think that's also because whenever
you use um
Claude to do an update and push to get
up, it adds itself as a contributor.
Oh.
So, it might be just one person
doing the code optimizations with
Claude.
Okay.
Uh okay, let me
cuz I saw that
recently.
So, that's Codex. Yeah, but I have them
in my projects as well.
You have both?
Yeah, yeah. When you ask
uh Claude code to push, it adds itself
as a contributor as well next to your
name. Yeah. And I read that like 40% of
the contribution on GitHub is uh has
Claude in it now.
Yeah, because so many people are using
it. Yeah. That's
Uh okay, so 20 minutes. We still We're
still running. We're still running.
Uh
Okay.
Ah
Excellent. Excellent.
Uh to the MVP, yes. It's committed to
the fit. Okay. Show us.
Excellent. All the work is committed.
Let's push to the branch and update the
task. Okay, we're getting there.
Uh okay, I will ask it install front end
design skill.
Uh the Entropic skill front end series
already imported at the company level,
blah, blah, blah.
Cool. Agent. Nice.
Okay, I I don't know how it built that
like Dota built it, but uh that's
honestly impressive. Yeah, but now comes
the next step. How do How are you going
to run it locally?
Uh I I will ask the CTO, but I expect it
like next year's like
project like normal stuff.
Uh with Ben.
Uh build MVP. Puff, puff. Next step,
review and merge.
Configure Oh, okay, [__] Uh fork key.
Okay. Um and we make them
uh optional
and we make uh
the
uh of
uh
uh of fuzz
op
tionals
So, I
can see the app.
Um
Yeah, we want a fuzz demo. Yeah.
Uh I'm doing uh
live stream
demo right now.
Say I
do the audience.
Okay.
Cool. Uh puff puff puff. Okay, and uh
do we uh by the way
do we use Ben?
Because
I like Ben.
[__]
Okay. Okay. Okay. CTO live boom boom
boom. Uh uh
uh CC leaks website is a good one. Okay.
A neural network that physically change
through use and then revert giving AI
the short-term memory that exist
What?
Yeah,
that's something different. I don't I
don't understand what I'm reading, but
uh thanks for your participation.
Independent AI resources. Thanks.
Uh okay. Cash 10 million. Okay. Cost
zero. Yes, let's go. That's what's up.
That's what we like.
Uh commented. Okay.
Go to the dashboard again. I would like
to see how many tokens have you go to.
Uh it's the cost, right? Yeah.
All right. All right.
Cost.
Ooh, 10 million we added additionally.
The Oh, yeah, that's ooh.
Uh that's not uh that's not nothing. Oh,
okay. What the [__]
Okay. Bye.
Uh
I
Hop la.
Cool.
Inbox uh build MVP, install the front
end.
I think it's done, right? Okay. And
build MVP.
What is it? Purple in review. Okay.
Uh can we make Okay, succeeded.
Why there's no message here?
Oh, that's from the side. Yeah.
Like yeah, uh I I ban it, right? It It's
not in the chat, right?
No, no, he's out of the chat. Cool.
Cool. Okay, inbox. Boom, GTM. Are we
contacting Disney now or what?
Uh
CMO is on board. Create first task. Oh
op op pair 16 building public content
strategy. Okay. Yeah. Uh He ignored us
on on contacting Disney for the
Oh, really? Yeah, I think so. I didn't
see it anymore.
Uh
Yeah, this is all about the hiring of
the CMO. I'm I'm kind of like uh kind of
sad.
Uh platform pres which channel first
uh Twitter. Okay.
So
Oh, okay. Comments.
Uh platform prioritization. We want uh
Twitter plus
LinkedIn
uh because it's
employer
Uh tag Saturday content calendar day by
day theme across four weeks uh origin
story product progress blah blah blah.
Voice positioning confident build a
tone. Let's go.
Uh this is so around where whitelist
funnel yes
metric
Uh we need a sub stack
to so I can
build an
uh
uh mailing
list.
Laugh.
Okay, where is the building build MVP?
Did you reply? And we Why?
I started it. Um
Yes. Okay, so that's the same.
Uh
hello.
Are you done?
Are you done, sir?
Wake up, [__]
Yeah, I think this one is is a good one.
Yeah. And the last comment. Uh so aside
from coding, I will have to learn
business management to deliver software.
I mean, ask AI to give you like
uh the best industry standards for
go-to-market last GTM. And you can also
like uh
go to skills.sh
and search from all of the
uh yeah, go-to-market marketing
uh etc. etc. Um
skills that you like don't learn
something, make your AI to learn the
best practices, and then the AI can
teach you what it learns. Yeah.
And if you need to do some task, just
ask it to tell you to do how to do it
step by step.
Yeah, exactly.
I keep it going through a website. I
will just say click here, click here.
Mhm.
How do you find Paperclip with Claude
20X? I made a mistake to use it at peak
time, and for me it was 10 10, but the
weekly usage was a lot for me. Yeah. I
mean, I had 200 I I at some point had
200 Claude Claude cut subscription at
200 uh months plus a Codex one at 200,
too.
Um but since like the 5.4, I I cancel
one Claude, and I do like more uh 5.4,
but I reach
um
like the limits, I think,
recently. I will I will have to wait. I
will have to switch back to Claude
instead of Codex now.
Uh because I'm maxed out, but um
and I'm coding all day.
But uh yeah, like 20X
I mean
20X should be enough.
>> Yeah. Like Mitchell, you never reach the
limit, right? No, no, and I still have
the 5X.
Damn. But I I still do a lot of
planning. I plan everything with Claude.
True, true, true. I don't do it like
here when I tell him just go. Mhm.
Yeah, maybe.
And he was adding so many features
before we check anything.
Yeah, I think that's like burning your
tokens as well. Keep on adding without
checking where we are.
Um and about the code quality. Okay, so
personally, it's been 6 months since I
didn't touch code. I did I don't I open
Cursor to check how many files I it has
been uh touched and see what like the
Git diff the Git Git diff of
um what has been done, but because
producing code is not cheap as [__]
Even if the code quality is [__] the AI
will handle it.
So, [snorts]
you don't really care about the code
quality anymore. I mean, you you care
about like because you need to deliver
good software, right? But if it's a code
like I don't even not not understand. I
understand my code, but I I don't even
um
yeah, review it because it will be
impossible anyway.
But do you check if it doesn't do
anything weird? Because sometimes
I want to send an empty value, and
instead of adding an empty value, it
just adds a default.
Yeah.
Uh
I
You don't have that kind of use case.
Maybe I do, but I don't know about it.
You haven't seen it yet.
>> Yeah. Uh sometimes it go crazy. Like you
know, it loop.
It just loop on a pro- on a problem. But
I
bro, I I don't even remember when I copy
paste a line of code to fix an AI issue.
I just You just like yeah, you just like
prompt a lot.
And sometimes for the same [__] right?
But uh
Yeah. Uh but the quality is good. Yeah.
Oh, yeah, [__] I said Electron, but
yeah, we should have done a Xcode app.
Stupid. Yeah, but it should have said it
himself, right? Oh, yeah.
And I don't know why, but like this one,
it just like succeeded. So Yeah, it
died.
What What the [__] happened?
But it looks like
all your bots are done, right?
Because no engineer has any icon next to
it. It's It looks like they are Yeah,
they're all IDs. Yeah, okay.
So
Okay, you're right. Uh so content
strategy
channel simplified to Twitter X plus
Substack. Okay, drop TikTok YouTube
shorts.
Discord. Okay, yeah, maybe maybe I
should not have done that, but yeah,
whatever.
Uh okay.
Give me the
uh
five first tweets
for the
timeline.
The X timeline.
Um for your first campaign.
Um
Define
the voice of the app and memorize
memorized it. Memorized
Oh.
Okay, ref.
And
cons cons and see.
Uh okay, okay. So, do you cut a lot of
peak? Uh yeah, I cut I cut a lot of
time, but we are like a European, so
maybe it's different. If we start early,
we are before the peak.
Yeah, I Yeah, I I Yeah, I didn't have a
check it like just like I'm not going to
stop coding because it's peak hours and
on traffic. And I use like a codex
anywhere in last for the last
two three weeks. I use codex like the
vast majority and cloud code becomes my
uh
default slash backup.
Oh, [__] it's 12 12:30. Damn. Oh, yeah,
we want to see what we have built for.
Yeah, true. Uh I hope token will become
cheaper in the next six months. Yeah,
100%. I'm always running into my weekly
limit and pay pay use cost more than
Bro, uh
create uh a secondary account. Like
>> Yeah, that's cheaper. Sign up for uh
OpenAI with a new email. You'll get uh
some free tokens. Don't pay pay use like
bro, this is mad.
And if you do it for simple tasks, just
set up a free AI on on another device
and use it locally.
>> you can even use open router slash free.
Back. Uh I I I never use I'm just
dropping that right now, but I never use
those models, but it they are free
models.
Yeah, so for research, that should be
good enough. Exactly.
Uh back path. Okay, so I want to see I
want to see uh give me five tweet uh
consistency. Bam. I want to talk to the
C CEO. Up. Uh why is everybody not
working?
>> And give the MVP.
Um
and I run the MVP app.
Uh
website and mobile. Yeah.
Back. Start up the server.
Yes.
Test the MVP. Bam.
I use the cloud full status bar that
show me when I'm in Oh, okay.
Yeah, I I've updated my status lines
too, but uh we I don't have I never
monitor that yet.
Um okay, file do not exist. Whatever,
whatever.
Don't exist yet. Let me check my small
workspace and company directory.
Um mhm.
Run task. Paper clip system. In QSO um
Okay.
Back. Replace.
QSO
path.
I think it should work.
Cuz
I think we have everything.
Babel. What the
Uh
dev. Okay, you know what? Maybe I can
even run it
uh myself
because
we don't have time no more.
Um let us go go burn. Let's go.
And it's falling.
Run dev.
Ooh. [snorts]
Okay. Life cycle blah blah blah.
Uh
path.
Cannot find module uh
Okay.
Path.
Uh path path path path path path path.
Back path.
Okay.
What? Okay, I'm I'm confused.
Good, let me try. Okay, and what about
the
um
Oh, no, it's good.
Wait.
I'm not in apps.
Stupid.
Uh I'm not in apps. Apps mobile uh
path
Maybe mobile.
Come on.
Back. Then
Okay.
Yeah, same issue.
Or did you paste it?
>> I pasted I pasted it.
Uh what do you [__]
I forgot how to do that. Uh
back
run dev.
Oh, same problem.
Yes, same problem.
>> Damn. Okay.
Web.
Edit back. Web. Edit web. Path path
path.
Okay. Back. Path. Uh
Let's go.
Not working. Nice.
Invalid answer.
What's the
Okay, public uh there's no Okay, there's
there's no thing web. Let's go.
Uh
what?
It did like the basic basics.
Yeah, that's really Okay, but why is it
not
Yeah, there there is a lot of [__]
missing.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh check this config.
And it said it was done, right? Yeah, I
think so.
Uh build the I mean, it it didn't say
anything here.
Oh, yeah, wait. Back in the PIF. Fastify
MongoDB. Yes, okay.
Play Expo. Okay.
Uh okay, so
uh
run MVP apps.
I
want you to run the mobile and web
and give me the panels. You know.
Um And now working again in paper clip,
right? Oh, see Sorry.
Sorry. Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Replace. Replace. Window. Paper clip.
Back.
So, yeah, run MVP. I'm talking to the
CEO. Yeah, see like instead of for task,
it should be should be a chat here. Mhm.
Uh back. CEO live testing MVP. Let's see
how it goes. Uh
running all [clears throat] the
services. Okay.
Looks like the next thing is still
running on port. Okay. Enjoy debugging.
That's it, bro. Yes. And maybe it should
not be a chat because you're giving it
tasks and the team should do everything.
So, it should not be you testing.
Uh okay, that's interesting.
Um
So, that's the difference, right? That
you said in the beginning. We have an
objective and not Yeah.
Because Yeah.
Yeah.
So, the next task should of the next
objective should be that the team should
be able to check everything and make
sure that it works properly on your
local host.
Oh, yeah, that would be the that would
be the task. Yeah, yeah, and it doesn't
matter how they do it. Just fix it. But
I have
Yeah, but I have like the if I have a QA
engineer, for example, uh it should
with a habit, it should have a like test
the app.
Yeah, so file a complaint to the CEO.
Yes.
Okay. Okay. Uh assign task. Um
uh
apps are
not working.
Uh mobile
and
web are not
starting properly.
Fix it.
Monitor
quality.
Path.
Ooh, CEO four lives.
Fix mobile Ooh, see? Mhm.
It created the issues
by itself. Yeah, so that's why you don't
need the chat. You just give it one one
thing and it will do everything itself.
That's lit.
QA engineer. Apps are not working.
Okay, paper clip. Whatever, whatever.
Bam.
I have a task now. Apps are not working.
Okay.
CEO CEO.
I I I'm afraid they're going to conflict
there between each other, no?
Doesn't matter. They should fix it as
well.
They are the team. They are the AI. They
are smarter than us.
>> They are smart so smart. Yeah, exactly.
And otherwise, the question is why did
you hire so many AIs? Uh because it's
it's funnier.
Uh mobile. Okay, build. Yes, mobile not
Expo blah blah blah.
Blocks research task assigned to CEO.
Okay. Oh, it cannot be tested until
this. Okay. Okay.
Demo down. What?
Do we have the content or not?
With writing following the campaign arc,
the announcement, building public from
day one, the problem.
Sora required desktop
first demo drop, the video clip
placeholder, honest competition. Where
are the
Where Where are the outputs?
Uh,
I need to check out the issue right 528.
Oh, okay. Where are they?
Did I comment? Did I comment?
Can I
Oh, wait a minute.
It should
Wait, what?
Okay, good good good. Nice nice nice.
They are in the Yeah, I was not in the
correct in the I was in the
configuration. We are building AI video
app mobile first. No No desktop
required. The idea if Sora is for
studios, this is for everyone else.
What?
Mhm, kind of [__]
The competition.
Quick take on AI video landscape. Sora,
great input, no mobile app Runway.
Warpful, steep learning curve. Pika
fast but limited. Well, my god, that's
pure AI garbage, bro. Yes.
Yeah.
It should focus on what it does
properly. Oh, CEO.
Yeah.
Uh, blocked. Test MVP, blocked, broken,
cannot start, build failed. Okay, let's
go. Mhm.
So, what did you do to fix it? Uh,
acknowledge, error is the same, blah
blah blah, incompatibility I flag
already tracked.
Nice.
Okay.
So,
it delegated to the CEO.
I mean, yeah, I think that's what
already happening with um
uh, Open Clober, but that's pretty
impressive to
Yeah.
>> it. Yeah, honestly, I think now it just
needs some time. You just keep on
checking given the task creation and
having all the AI agents do the task,
connect back to CEO, test again, and
just keep on going until it's all fixed.
100%. I think should we stop here
because we like we're going to have
>> Yeah.
Maybe when we post video, we can show
some screenshots of the eventually
design and everything that was created.
We can even continue next week.
Ooh, that's even better. Maybe Disney is
in by then. Yes.
Yeah, like and I can push it live on
Vercel and uh
after cluster. Yeah, and then like I
have the server less up.
So, yeah, I'm going to prompt it, push
it to production next week, and then we
can continue to build this uh
uh, this app and see Yeah, it's creating
some bugs.
Um, and
>> some proper debugging.
Yes.
Um
and we can have like a a series or
something, that could be cool. Or we can
even like Yeah, if not building directly
on doing the live session, we can come
back to it and show it to the people
because I mean, it's kind of cool like
to have like your defense and slickens
chat and stuff, so
>> And even if they want to see some
features, just post it between the video
here on YouTube. We will try to add it.
Exactly, we can build in public with
Paper Clips. Okay, guys, are you are you
still here like your defense like and uh
slickens?
If you
do you want to see a series on this
channel where
we're going to build this open Sora app?
That would be would be lit. That would
be cool.
Yeah.
Well, just let us know.
Yeah, do do you have like
Mitchell, do you want to do the
conclusion based based on your like
first impression of Paper Clip? Oh, I
was
first thinking, yeah, we have another
one, but it actually looks good. You
have a great controller.
Uh,
even the design that they added, it just
works. So, I'm really looking forward to
start testing it and build some of my
own apps.
Nice. That's That's awesome. Yeah, let's
see what we can do.
Let's Let's see what we can do, and
let's see if we can close like 1 million
in revenue by end of end of Q2. Oh,
[__] the end of Q2 is
I don't know. Oh, wait, we just closed
Q1. My bad. Yeah, but
let's see what it does. I'm not going to
put in make me a million dollars. I
think I'm going to put in
check how they have a how the strategy
of this company works and rebuild it for
me,
and see if I can do it as well. Just
copy the strategy of a successful one.
Yeah.
Mhm. Okay. Well, so let us know how it
goes.
We'll do.
Thanks everyone. Thank you so much. Uh,
subscribe because you are probably not
subscribers. There is only 500 100 not
even subscribers in the
>> need three more.
Just three more? Oh, just three more.
God, it was by Rub. It looks cool, too.
Bro, I can I can test We we can test new
[__] every day, bro. That's That's too
much too much.
By the way, that's the next one for next
week.
Um
It's a lot for
like Paper Clips, but for teams. We
don't We don't have a team. We We just
working like in indie devs, so We are
the team. Exactly. We We don't need a
team because we have AI. Yeah, yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Anyway, guys, subscribe to the channel.
Thank you for being in the chat.
Mitchell, thank you for your time. Yes,
you too.
Bye-bye. Cheers.